luis garcia throws for the stros 0-2
with an era of three he was ranked as
the astros number six prospect entering
the season
first batter he'll face this afternoon
will be sam hagerty
the 2-2
strike three call on the outside corner
frozen with 95 on the black one out jose
mar malayo stands in left-handed hitter
banning 178 302 on base percentage three
homers eight rbis
marmalayos looking to drive in the
game's first run luis garcia ready
2-1 shot the other way correa has to
back up strong throw picked by yuli just
in time to get marmalajos
tough play on both sides correa and eule
save a run
mariner strand a runner and after a half
inning
mariners nothing astros coming up you
say kikuchi is going to go for seattle
0-1 with a 570 era he's a lefty
29-year-old making his fifth start of
the season his 46th overall major league
start
jose altuve digging in to start things
off for the astros batting 316.
here's the next offer on the way swing
and a foul tip into the glove of the
catcher tom murphy hangs on to it for
strike three
so one away for the astros here in the
bottom of the first inning right away
you say with his first strike out of the
afternoon
devin white leads it off against luis
garcia worked around a one-out double by
seeger in the
first swing and a miss gets him with
that slider
picks up his second strikeout of the day
kevin white goes down for the first down
so two out no one on for the right
fielder dylan borb adding 111 in 24
games 240 on base percentage a home run
six rbis
the one-two
swing and a miss got him on the slider
and luis garcia a couple of strikeouts
in a one-two-three inning
we're through one and a half astros
nothing
it's taylor tremell leading things off
facing luis garcia
his next pitch
swinging a fastball is rocking it out to
right field punch deep and gone into the
second row right over the leap
of mccormick in right field taylor
trammell going deep to begin the top of
the third
he has put the mariners in front one
nothing
number four on the season for the rookie
here's kyle seeger the one guy in this
mariners lineup that the astros have not
been able to solve in this series sega
now six for 13 against the astros with
three doubles in a home run
garcia's wind up in the pitch swing and
a miss got him on a change up four punch
outs
now for luis garcia we'll go to the
bottom of the third with the mariners
leading one nothing here's
chaz mccormick right fielder
the 2-2
swing at a miss center cut cut fastball
and he blows it right past chaz
mccormick
second strike counter for kikuchi one
away
one out one on jason castro now batting
chase that that's a good strikeout
his third and there's two down here in
the third end
one nothing mariners leading the astros
top of the fifth inning
dylan moore will stand in against luis
garcia he's allowed three hits one of
those a home run by taylor trammell 2-2
swing and a miss got him on the cutter
away and dylan moore is the fifth
strikeout victim of luis garcia one out
taylor trammell the batter he homered
his last time
3-2
at the knees on the outside corner
strike three call
trammell asking alfonso marquez about it
and that is six strikeouts
for garcia two out two down for the
astros baron is leading one to nothing
on the tremel home run and that'll bring
up right fielder chaz mccormick
here's the stretch and the 2-2
swinging a ground ball to third near the
bag waiting for the big hop seeger got
it tossed across in time to get
mccormick so kyle seeger has been
outstanding
as he always is over there at third base
and that's it for the astros of what a
performance to this point by you say
kikuchi after five it's the mariners one
the astros nothing now it's kyle
seeger's turn he's one for two with a
double back in the first struck out in
the third
oh one
that is a line into the shift caught by
altuve it was knuckling and sinking as
it got to him he made the catch in the
outfield and then went down on his hands
and knees after coming up with it two
out
while straw will lead off the inning
against you kikuchi
the coochie so far through five innings
has allowed two walks and that is it
two fly ball outs
three strikeouts the rest have been on
the ground
you say come set
here's the 2-2
swing and a miss for strength three
good pitch buried low beneath the knees
straw tries to take a bite out of it
comes up empty
and you say picks up his fourth
strikeout today one away in the sixth
now it's jason castro
he struck out back in the third shift is
on for castro left-handed hitting
catcher
you save one-two
swing and a miss for strike three a
cutter gets castro back-to-back
strikeouts for kikuchi to open up the
sixth inning he's got five on the
afternoon
to the top of the order jose altuve now
two via strikeout and a ground out
kikuchi had about touve here's his o2
swing and a miss for strike three boy
did he make altuve looks silly a slider
well outside and buried in the derp
altuve comes up empty and with that
kikuchi strikes out the side in order
to the seventh one-nothing america
trammell
on here to face abreu
with two outs and two on
here's the 2-2
ground ball to the right side and it's
gloved by guriel to his backhand flips
it to abreu
in time to get jermell
bregman today is walked and
fouled out down right field line to
dylan moore
bregman holds the bat low on the knob
here's the pitch
swing and a miss for strike three a
cutter buried shoelaces high and bregman
is strikeout victim number seven for usa
kikuchi who has punched four straight
tickets of astros hitters
here comes correa
correa oh for two hit into a double play
and also grounded out
he's set here comes the 3-2 from kikuchi
and it's rifled to right center and it's
going to get down
and go to the wall
correa the second with a double
and there goes the no header
tyne run at second go ahead at the plate
dangerous batter in julie guriel
you say fires home
swinging a high chop halfway to the
pitcher's mount a sliding stop what a
play by you say kikuchi it looked like
he was sliding home he fielded that
halfway between the mount and home plate
popped up and threw a seed onto first
base to get guriel
so two outs runner on second base for
lebanese diaz who's grounded out in
flight out
diaz the right-handed hitter climbs in
94 pitches for you say here's the
offering swinging a ground ball chopping
only man left side jp crawford is there
throws onto first base
and plenty of time to get elected miss
diaz
seven brilliant innings in houston for
you say kikuchi just one hit
one-nothing mariner
and that'll bring up miles straw
here's the stretch
and now the 2-2 on the way to straw here
she comes swinging a line shot in the
left field coming in and making the
catch hagerty sam hagerty into a slide
is able to get there in time and he
makes the grab and that will retire the
side what a catch
by sam hagerty the last mayor's
one-nothing win with only a run via the
homer seth smith
this date back in 16 a winner for felix
hernandez how about that
to the day one nothing mariners and here
is carlos correa
now the old one pitch breaking ball
swinging at a fly ball into shallow
center field tramell racing in slides
and he makes the catch from the seat of
his pants big smile on his face and the
ball game is over the mariners shut out
the houston astros this afternoon here
in houston taylor tremell with the
game-winning home run and a game saving
kent